mais d'abord le retour du tristement
célèbre chirurgien de jonzac le
pédophile comparaît à partir
d'aujourd'hui devant les assises de
charente maritime pour viol et agression
sexuelle présumée sur quatre victimes
trois sont originaires de loches où il a
exercé dans les années 90 premier volet
d'une affaire vertigineuse qui compte
plus de 300 victimes potentielles
lucas chopin enfin huit mois après le
report de son procès joël le scouarnec
et jugé à saintes en charente-maritime
face à lui quatre plaignantes dont ses
deux nièces
amélie lévesque fait partie de ces
victimes présumées son cas sera évoqué
lors d'un prochain procès pour autant
elle attend impatiemment le premier
verdict nous l'avions rencontrée chez
elle il y a quelques semaines on va
vivre ce procès parce que parce que
c'est le premier parce que on espère
qu'il va prendre déjà une peine lourde
et puis après l'autre ce sera du surplus
mais des ailes celui ci avec la petite
fille sa voisine jeu ça a été prouvé
donc je pense que la lourde peine elle
est là elle va être là au total joël le
scouarnec pourrait être coupable de
viols et agressions sexuelles aggravées
sur 312 victimes pour la plupart mineurs
les faits auraient été commis entre 1986
et 2014
johan le scouarnec éminent chirurgien à
l'époque à exercer dans de nombreux
établissements dont l'hôpital de loches
trois des quatre victimes représentées
aujourd'hui sont également originaires
de la ville
le verdict est attendu pour jeudi soir
jour de son 70e anniversaire
joël le scouarnec encourt jusqu'à 20 ans
de réclusion criminelle